[Music]
right time for the pledges very own
version of hold the front page team take
a look at this front page of a recent
edition of the Bristol Post and tell me
what you see
Majid in a sentence is that the guy
running from it that's right
Carol what did you see okay fair enough
June any problems with it well is that
really his picture that's really the
mayor's picture okay
it's not running for that is the mayor
and why they made him look like a
criminal with like a close-up monster
you see alpha goes to top of the class
we've had racist statues races
advertising campaigns and now we have a
new first a racist front page when that
edition of the paper hit the streets it
lived up to the nickname of front pages
given in the trade and caused quite a
splash to you and me but not a flaw it
might look like a classic regional paper
focusing on the local mayor's ambitious
plans for his city's future but to the
ever-expanding race industry on this
occasion in the shape of Bristol's
Commission for racial equality they saw
a criminal mug shot that was quotes
offensive and inappropriate and failed
to promote a positive image for our
local black leadership
regrettably while the editor initially
dismissed this hokum as quotes beyond
ludicrous he since apologized and
promised an extra layer of consideration
in the newsroom you know in truth you
can find a fence anywhere if you choose
after all sometimes offer even pretends
to be upset with me a picture the way
that we use images sometimes it's subtle
it's very powerful in how it shapes our
subconscious I just want to show you
some papers for today picked at random
that also featured politicians on their
front page okay
here's Tom Watson right oh he's wearing
a suit right
he's come Watson again home suits tie
Boris Johnson
there's his suit his papi he's clearly a
podium with some speakers you get the
picture I do and you illustrated bro all
I would say is respectfully when I went
around the rest of the panel and it
comes back to what I said first time out
if you if you wish you can seek and find
offense in anything you the way the
picture was crop like it was actually
isn't a particularly attractive front
page but I defy most people to see race
when they look at that front page I'm
not saying that particularly attractive
one it's not but I don't see we showed
this panel a picture of Marvin Rees the
mayor of Bristol as he usually looks
also like these and I thought hot young
guy I didn't see the fact I didn't know
it was the fact he was the mayor and in
the suit when you see yeah I think he
looks like a hot you go when you see him
in the suit I think he looks 15 years
older but that's my point
oh can I just finish Carol and then you
have your time properly I just want to
give you some context why I react like
that name go ahead there is a perception
that black men have criminal tendencies
I remember one of the most formative
experiences when I was young I just got
to university I was a pressure my
boyfriend who was back came to visit me
and the porters wouldn't let him in and
they called me and they said you should
have warned us if someone who looks like
a criminal was going to visit you you
know they want him crying to be raised
as their perception was if you see a
young black man he looks like a criminal
that is a reality in our society and
also there is just quickly last thing
there is some data on this so for
example in 2015 you guys did a poll
about people's prejudices and it found
that there is a difference between how
honest people think a white man in his
twenties is to a black caribbean man in
his 20s and a Pakistani man the the
honesty they strive to a Pakistani man
is almost half a white man and then they
asked people and written who they think
seems more violent just
literally based on their ethnicity and
they found that a black caribbean man in
his 20s is perceived as almost twice as
violent as a white man in his twenties
so there really is this perception it's
something that is very much alive and
that comes from somewhere it comes in my
opinion from very subtle sometimes and
insidious images like this there's
anyone had bothered to read the words on
that front page is actually introducing
a new circle line bus route yes so it's
nothing to do with this picture or
anything else but what really upsets me
is Mike Norton the papers editor has
caved into this nonsense on the phone
day one when he was criticized by
certain sections of community he
actually said this was beyond ludicrous
and then he came I think it's a shame
because wait you know because you see a
black person's face on the front page of
a newspaper not dressed the way you
wanted to be dressed him dude it doesn't
mean it's racist I'll actually read your
statement from the editor in a moment
June did you see any race when you saw
the front page in the Bristol Post well
when I saw that and I know Marvin Reese
I've known him a very long time when I
saw that image I didn't recognize it as
him I didn't know who it was I had no
idea and I think too after was pointed I
think a fourth point is completely spot
on because when you see who Marvin Rees
actually is the image they use has
nothing to do with who the Rossellini
well I think it's back to what she's
saying in terms of perception I wonder
if they would have done the same thing
to a white politician and I would say
probably not so that's I think that's
let me start by saying I think the point
that we made earlier about unintentional
jerks falling flat this could have been
an unintentional front-page that was
simply a mistake to publish it but they
may not have intended explicitly to be
racist but I think actually wanted it
surely that's otherwise you're saying
what I'm about to coax okay so with all
that throat-clearing I don't think we
have to remember if you remember the
footballers controversy where
footballers a black footballer who
bought a home was treated one way and a
white footballer who bought a home in
the newspapers was treated another way
Raheem Sterling and
think that whether it's that or this
google three black kids and Google three
white teenagers on Google and see what
the algorithm produces well explain to
the viewers what what happens when you
do the algorithm on its a is it's not a
human being but it's trained by human
beings the algorithm when you Google
three black teenagers shows three mug
shots and when Google three white
teenagers shows a happy family playing
bath nice and friendly wholesome that
was 2006 sixteen has changed but that
was what the AI naturally produced as a
result of humor trained by humans right
so I think I think the important point
here behind the story is there is a
societal implicit bias that we need to
acknowledge is we need to acknowledge
and address that regardless of the
intentions in this specific case it does
reinforce an overall societal implicit
bias I wonder why they didn't just show
him in that other photo do we know
whether he was actually upset about this
because I would have thought as a
journalist that if a mayor gets the
whole of the front page to actually talk
about what he's doing in the business
and the stuff he's creating I think most
mayor's would be pretty delighted not if
the image is depicting them as a primary
figure of fear I'm curious because I
think I've explained why to me that
feeds into a narrative that is many
people's perception June imagine have
also touched on that I'm just curious
having listened to us whether you take
at all seriously that that I know you
didn't see it that way but Jake
seriously the other people I see the
mayor that way I see the mayor of this
area talking about a new circle line bus
route because I've just read the words
on the front page that's what I say I
swear to God I see nothing else it our
picture differently do you take that
convinced me that it's racist what the
editor said Bristol Post editor Mike
Norton there was absolutely no
deliberate attempt to undermine Marvin
reason the way in which his portrayal
has been perceived but perception is key
here and frankly this organization reaps
what it is sown in that respect our
thinking felt short on this occasion
what should have been a positive page
about a black leaders vision for a city
was undermined by the way we presented
it we will work even harder to ensure
that does not happen there's no
intention there was clearly by that
statement they didn't intend to be
racist but they've recognized as a
perception that is important to be aware
of and that's that force point that we
we shouldn't keep repeating those same
mistakes why are you doing and when we
make the mistake I think this is a
really important point to make in the
sense I often with these issues what
happens is when you are from the
majority group and a minority raises to
you raises it to you the natural
response is to go on the defense and to
somehow feel that you're under attack
and I think the way he responded is
brilliant and should be commended
because he's acknowledged he didn't know
he was doing it but now that the point
has been raised he will do better next
is be Delta by the whoever own